in indonesia's west kalimantan in the
city of pontianak
these people were waiting to welcome
their family and friends
but anticipation turned to devastation
as they heard flight sj182 had gone
missing
this man was waiting for his daughter
i was supposed to pick them up this is
my first daughter
i won't ever see them again more than 60
people were on board the sri wajaya
flight from
jakarta to pontianak infants and
children were among the passengers
the plane lost contact just four minutes
after takeoff
controllers of the jakarta approach saw
that the plane was not flying at 75
degrees
but was heading northwest the air
traffic control asked the pilots
to confirm where they were heading not
long after within seconds
the plane went missing from the radar
the boeing 737-500 was at least
25 years old the flight had been delayed
by 30 minutes due to heavy rain in the
indonesian capital
a search team says they believe they
have found debris from the plane
in the sea close to the thousand islands
north of jakarta
the national search and rescue agency
and navy have dispatched teams to the
area
fishermen say they heard a loud crash
authorities have established a crisis
center here at sukhar no hata
airport indonesia's busiest airport for
relatives of those on board
to speak with authorities and find out
what happened to their loved ones
they've also established a crisis center
in pontianak
in west kalimantan for relatives who
were waiting at the airport
for their loved ones to disembark in
jakarta
arya found out his family had been on
board
5 30 i heard the news i asked my friends
to make sure that it was right and it
was
four of my family members were among the
victims
sriwajya has never had a major safety
incident
authorities say they're working swiftly
to find out what went wrong